this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
thank you for joining us i'm john
langland we do begin with this breaking
news happening right now in the east
valley clark county fire says two dogs
have died in a mobile home fire this is
out near nellis and twain we have bianca
holman live at the scene with the very
latest bianca quite a situation out
there
yeah still very active we've got yellow
crime scene tape still water still
flowing from these fire trucks here and
investigators on scene just trying to
figure out what happened at this teal
home on the east side of the valley we
spoke with a couple neighbors who they
didn't want to go on camera but they
tell us they heard a woman yelling for
help so a person across the street
looked out our window and saw the fire
and called 9-1-1 and that all happened
around 10 this morning
five fire engines 35 personnel they all
responded to this incident neighbors say
the woman was yelling about a baby being
inside so when the fire department
arrived they rescued a little boy who
neighbors say could be around three or
four years old now we are told that that
child was taken to the hospital no word
yet on their condition and also there
were two people who were treated here on
scene at the fire and then also
estimated damages and the cause still
under investigation we of course will
provide an update once we learn more
bianca holmen live local now